une soirée qui s'annonce donc animé
quelle que soit l'issue du match c'est
un important dispositif de sécurité sera
déployé par tout en France sur les
Champs-Élysées les magasins installe des
systèmes de protection 10000 policiers
et gendarmes seront mobilisés c'est à
peu près le double en tout cas le double
pour Paris et sa petite couronne ça
banlieue et puis le triple pour
certaines villes de provinces on sait
que ce soit la France ou le Maroc il y
aura des manifestations de jouets vous
l'avez lu le journal Le Monde hier il y
a cinq pages sur France Maroc il y a
quatre pagées de Miss une Maroc et la
une c'est des supporters marocains alors
après on en pense ce qu'on en veut parce
que c'est le Maroc il y a une sorte de
relan un peu raciste je crois
un minimum de commentaires moi je veux
dire que les Marocains évidemment ont
raison d'être fier de leur équipe
nationale évidemment la fête doit se
faire de manière respectée pour les
règles de la République pour apporter sa
contribution à ce qu'on appelle déjà ici
un exploit légendaire la Compagnie
Royale s'est lancé le défi d'organiser
un ce pont aérien 9000 passagers
pourront ainsi supporter l'équipe
nationale à Doha sauf qu'elle arrive à
l'aéroport comme ces images à l'aéroport
de Casablanca bah voilà ce qu'ils ont eu
la surprise de découvrir sur le tableau
d'affichage des départs tous les vols à
destination de doigts annulées alors
qu'il y en avait un prévu toutes les
heures c'est simple sur les 30 avions à
fêter spécialement pour cette
demi-finale seul 14 ont été vraiment
programmées donc la moitié ce que je vis
depuis maintenant 4 mois avant même la
médiatisation la politisation c'est
d'abord et avant tout une épreuve
personnelle dont je n'ai rien vu venir
et selon la compagnie Royal Air Maroc
les autorités
qatari ont ensuite limité l'accès à leur
territoire à seulement 7 avions donc
encore la moitié
j'avais été menacé par mon épouse qui
m'avait dit si le divorce ne se fait pas
à l'amiable et à toutes mes conditions
je peux faire exploser ta carrière
politique et visiblement les menaces ont
été mises à exécution parce que la
France septième puissance mondiale va en
être réduite à rationner l'électricité
pour ses concitoyens bon je pense que
nous pouvons l'éviter et je pense que
nous sommes dans la bonne voie pour
éviter des coupures d'électricité cet
hiver ce qu'il y a de moins banal
brusque tout ça c'est qu'ensuite
évidemment sitôt que mon épouse avait
déposé cette main courante il y a eu en
effet ce que moi j'ai appelé un lâchage
médiatique pendant trois mois je me suis
tue plus exactement j'ai réservé ma
parole à la justice pensant que elle
seule pourrait rétablir les faits et
j'ai vu cette espèce de cirque oui
adrien a admis un geste dont il dit
lui-même qu'il est inexcusable il a
accepté les conséquences judiciaires et
politiques
et bien oui moi je ne crois pas
qu'Adrien soit fini d'aucune manière
cette histoire peut être estampillée du
saut des violences conjugales oui il y a
eu une erreur de ma part une faute il y
a eu des faits aussi qui ont été commis
par mon épouse mais j'ai réservé cela la
justice je pense qu'il faut qu'il se
représente devant les électeurs
électriques puisque le contrat au nom
duquel il a été élu finalement à ses
modifié à changer a été entaillé
entachée et donc il faut qu'il se
représente dans l'interview de la Voix
du Nord je prends la précaution de dire
je ne peux pas accuser le ministère de
l'intérieur parce que je n'ai pas de
quoi l'affirmer mais néanmoins une
réalité que vous avez fait non non une
réalité
c'est que cette réalité c'est que des
journalistes m'ont dit que ça venait de
là il dit femme gravement les agents du
ministère de l'Intérieur a commencé par
les policiers bien évidemment j'imagine
qu'il pense à eux et donc
j'imagine pas l'intérieur de distribue
pas comme ça les fiches de justice kinda
d'ailleurs pas à l'ensemble des journaux
français dans les minutes à peine
peut-être n'était elle-même pas encore
rentrée au domicile que le contenu de sa
main courante et dans les salles de
rédaction parisienne ce qui est pas la
première fois pour les élus de la France
insoumise je le constate ils ont un
problème manifestement avec la police
mais enfin attaquant ainsi les services
de la police nationale je déposerai
plainte au nom des agents du ministère
de l'Intérieur donc plutôt que de porter
plainte contre moi qui n'ai absolument
pas dit fermé puisque je n'affirm rien
je souhaiterais que le ministre Darmanin
m'accompagne plutôt et soit soucieux de
la recherche de savoir qui a fait fuiter
le contenu de ses mains courantes